man I remember you know when I was young
we're just happy to have whatever and
the only goal when you were a child when
I was young was not to get you ass beat
by your mother or your father
I remember this boy you that one of the
U of A kids had his family that lived
down the street from us called the uvas
and this one boy stuck I don't know what
his full name was Stanislaus or
something I think they were from they
might have been Dutch I mean I don't
know if they were Dutch or not there
were pieces of [ __ ] but they might have
been you know Dutch [ __ ] but they the
Uvas had this one of the boys stuck he'd
had his um and it's a nick that was a
nickname Stanislas I think was his real
name but he had his fingers glued
together two of his fingers and I mean
you know not just a line a super glum
talking a whole damn you know one of
those green bottles with the red cap
they'd really put it on him and he had
to I mean he was just a dang you know a
weblo scout all the time he had that
double up you know and he couldn't get
him off never got him separated as long
as I knew him which is probably nine
years and so he would always suck on his
fingers you know and he would just enjoy
that glue enjoy that hit you know and um
I don't even know where this story was
going were we talking about oh we're
talking about when you oh so one time he
stayed over so one time stuck stayed the
night at my place my mother's house that
I lived in when I was a child because we
all live together because we were family
and and this is when we were still a
family when we were still you know all
living together he and and my and and we
and so our big thing was sneak down at
night makes you know cook some [ __ ] and
oven some basic ass [ __ ] crackers you
know maybe a little bit of cheese on
maybe a little bit of um you know
[ __ ] just bop him up with that
American slice you know maybe take a
slice of American and cut it in a for
bamm-bamm you know put them crackers you
know get them you know
a pepper on them [ __ ] you know fire
him up and we get that oven heated get
that oven you know crank but you know
the light from the kitchen it could hit
the under the doorway about my mother's
room and if I made too much noise she
could hear us so you didn't want mom to
hear us and you wanted to get that food
made and one of the most amazing things
I ever saw was one time we had the oven
open right and the uva's were one of the
toughest families I've ever met in my
life one of them had I mean this kid
might have had damn two spines in his
back and something that happened to his
teeth it all grew in on one side of his
mouth there was just one huge tooth I
mean this tooth was probably two and a
half inches long and when that thing
broke through his gums I mean I can't
even imagine when he was teething as a
child you know the rest of us have to
have ointment and gel and you know get
novocaine shot up just for sprouting a
couple little enamel nuggets you know a
couple little goat little a couple
little baby ghosts and here he had this
two and a half inch grim reaper rolling
out of his gums fear into his you know
into his mouth and it was can't even
imagine but anyhow anyhow we're making
these you know we're making these
cookies you know we firing up these
hitters down there with these crackers
and cheese a little bit of pepper maybe
some you know whatever else maybe mixing
up a can of that orange juice they used
to have that orange juice it was like
this that is frozen chunk in the freezer
and you got that chunk at first you
would take it add this tight white
plastic cord around the cannon McAmis
freezing cold the can't had ice on the
outside the can didn't want you getting
inside of it like cans nowadays it's got
these easy peel tops and you know it
makes like a when you open something not
the cans we grew up with those frozen
[ __ ] orange juice may you end if you
had no JMU added you know I mean you had
to [ __ ] sit there and babysit that
thing you had a sweet talk it it was
frozen you could barely hold on to it
and it had frozen orange juice inside
it and I don't even think it was real
orange so it was just orange [ __ ] ice
but it was a huge chunk of it and so the
thing was to get that ice out and get it
into a thing of water then you beat it
around this jug of water with a wooden
spoon and then you got you don't really
have orange juice but what you have is
sort of lightly or you have kind of
orange II looking water with a huge
chunk of kind of orange stuff in it in
the pitcher so anyhow means so anyhow me
and stuck come down make that right then
we start getting uh we're getting these
hitters that we put together we slippin
them in into the oven and these had no
gray block hit us you know these are
basic run-of-the-mill [ __ ] 4th Ward
Covington Lousiana out there off Lee
Road you know back there by the bailed
hay dealership right down from ozone
field you know right there where they
got all the animal carcasses out in a
ditch this is those hitters you know
this is more these backwoods hitters
that we made you know it's the cracker
them saltines got that American cheese
that little hit of frickin their square
okay so you know the shadiest cheese too
you can see through it a little bit
you're like oh this [ __ ] looks
questionable it's not even taste like
cheese it just tastes kind of like
yellow it tastes like a little like like
uh it tastes like um like harsh yellow
and then you got that pepper boy we
douse these [ __ ] up with pepper right
so we put it to tray of him in the oven
quiet quiet quiet don't wake my mother
right don't and my mother was a kind of
lady that laid in bed waiting to get
[ __ ] woken up I don't even think she
went to sleep I think she just closed
your eyes and waited to beat someone and
I'll tell you that's the toughest thing
I ever seen happen out of somebody I
don't know what happened we're in the
dark we get the oven open we get the
thing stuck falls on to the oven door Oh
been oven door blazing hot I mean this
thing had been preheated we only
preheated things to 400 we only burned
[ __ ] in my house nothing was ever cooked
correctly it was either [ __ ] burnt
because here's what happened you put it
in 400 was the only thing we knew you
put it in a 400 then you forgot about it
and then you smelled smoke and you ran
downstairs and then you got your ass
beaten and that was how we cooked in our
house but stuck fell on this hot door
with no t-shirt no shirt on his back and
he held it in it was dark in the kitchen
and I could see the pain on his face
when stuck you've a hit that hot door
with his probably 11 or 12 year old
skinned and held that pain inside of him
it was just a different time and now you
go upstairs you google you do all kinds
of you probably call the police on your
parents all of this all of that man I
remember just you know we put him on his
stomach we laid the cold towel was on
him put put the towels we had some
towels that were some spare towels and
we we put these towels into water into
cold water and laid him on his back but
man it looks scary his back bubbled up I
mean look like the it looked like just
like a his whole back look like a top of
a meatloaf kind of and then you know
just a different time though you know it
was just a different time when things
were different that's all I'm saying it
was a different time when things were
different and I miss it a little bit and
stuck had a brother and and this was an
older brother could have been an uncle
and that's the kind of the family it was
you know it was sort of that you know I
mean the you know the DNA kind of did
what it did
you know I'm not everybody's got that
you know that family tree you know some
people got that family cactus and
there's a fern hanging off of it over
here and you got a couple of [ __ ] you
know you got an owl living in one of the
branches and he's you know selling
selling coke but you had a he had a
brother that had moles on his back right
and this moles these different moles and
moles are little pieces of cancer or
whatever that live in your body
sometimes they try and get you get or
not cancer but they're basically they're
basically like the devil's little death
buttons and they might have cancer in a
minute and if the devil presses them and
pushes that cancer in your skin then you
can get sick but sometimes the devil
just leaves them on your body and you
just dancing around with these fancy
little you know benign and malignant
studs you know you up there stunting and
flexing with these studs aren't you and
and that's what happened with with the
oldest Yuva brother he had tattoos he
had all kind of tattoos he had tattoos
and one of them was a constellation of
his moles he had made a constellation
and I don't want to say it was Orion 's
belt it could have been a little Dipper
and we only knew like three
constellations back then but those were
the days man those were the days when
you nested in this wasn't so much
information out there you know and I
think um
you know over time things like that
evolved out you know when I was young
those things were fun those were like
the people in my neighborhood and those
were you know and we played football
every every day we play football if it
didn't rain we played football then we
played in the street we played in the
street man did I saw this kid one time
got his head run ran his face right into
an open mailbox open mailbox one of the
black lenses you know this hardy ones
the metal ones now everybody's got a
plastic mailbox they don't want their
mail to get hurt when it gets delivered
but we had the metal and I saw this boy
get his face stuck right in it had to go
get to people's dads to come out and
help him get to get his mailbox out the
get his face out the mailbox and those
were the times man and the kids were
tough and things were different man and
it was just different good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one